eindeutig schuhabdrücke von eben keine
hier stiefel das sieht mir sehr
nach dem ersten zeichen von elser aus
china seien herzlich kommen sondern
wieder deutlich da draußen das gedacht
haben ein heute ist kein tag zu machen
heute ist kein tag zum lustigsein denn
deutschland entweder in deutschland wird
weiterhin von einem disney charaktere
heimgesucht diese heimsuchen und
verfolgung wichtigsten charaktere
beschränkt sich seltsamerweise auf eine
einzige person in deutschland der name
ist glaube ich ich glaube rebecca wien
oder sortiert vor zwei tagen wieder
aufgeladen suche um drei uhr nachts
niemals im winter elser aus rosen zwei
kammern aufhalten ziegler zu und der
blick in die beschreibung des videos
lässt uns noch weitere sachen finden
nämlich suche um drei uhr nachts niemals
im winter elser aus rosen 2 1 sieg als
der bio titel nochmal machen nicht
selber nach mit freundin freund vater
mama oder sogar nachbar dieses
experiment leute also schreibt euch
hinter die ohren mache nicht selber nach
mit freundin freund vater mama oder
sogar nachbar dieses experiment also
allein von euch da draußen die sie jetzt
gerade gedacht haben hey dieses
experiment würde ich gerne mit meinem
nachts einfach machen
nein das bin zufällig spiel gerade
charlie charlie und genau danach
schreibt mich diese elsa nummer an und
sagt ich soll raus kommen und sie suchen
mit irgendwie drei schneeflocken images
oder so ich weiß nicht ob das etwas zu
bedeuten hat leute bestandsaufnahme wo
stehen wir gerade also wir sind auch der
timeline von rebecca wings elsa frozen
wahnsinn irgendwo glaube ich relativ in
der mitte sehr schon ein paar videos zu
elsa gemacht sie hat mit ihr natürlich
eine facetime ist ja klar und jetzt hat
elsa älter würden behaupten dass es
nicht echt ist was natürlich unsinn ist
ihr auf whatsapp geschrieben drei
schneeflocken images und jo komma in den
wald und sie so alles klar nicht
unbedingt
die klügste entscheidung ich glaube das
ist kein gutes zeichen wenn schon
charlie sagt ihre zauberkraft ist die
gefahr und sie schickt mir noch drei
schneeflocken emo die ist dazu leute
gar nicht gut ja okay also ich versuche
immer irgendwie dahinter zu steigen also
sie hat irgendwie immer was da erzählt
sie von charlie
also ich glaube damit meint sie charlie
charlie was irgendwie so ein komisches
spiel ist es nicht so was mal so
spaßeshalber gemacht wurde und wieso
geister zu beschwören oder so auf jeden
fall stand ist gerade gemacht haben zu
elsa und dann als elsa ihr 33
schneeflocken images geschickt also die
kacke am dampfen vielleicht wäre es auch
mal gar nicht mal so schlecht weil ich
habe das spiel noch nicht komplett
beendet man muss es auch noch beenden
vielleicht wäre es gar nicht mal so
schlecht wollte 88 mal bitte auf diese
text anwendung hier bekommen wir nämlich
noch mal alles an weisheit was wir dazu
braucht man muss charlie fragen ob man
das bei enten darf und sich
verabschieden soll ja auch das bitte mal
hinter die ohren schreiben also ihr
könnt nicht erwarten das wenn ihr
einfach so geister beschwört mit charlie
charlie dass sie denn einfach danach
gehen könnt oder so auch in der in der
geisterbeschwörung muss man höflich sein
und sich verabschieden aber ich könnte
ihnen ja fragen irgendwie könntest du
anna dazu bringen mich an zu schreiben
oder mich anzurufen weil das kann er mit
ja oder nein beantworten
es wäre vielleicht noch eine möglichkeit
was also ich gebe mir wirklich mühe
jetzt wieder hinter zu steigen aber was
ist jetzt die aktuelle situation
sie will elsa irgendwie nochmal
erreichen weil ich meine sie wie sie
muss da jetzt raus gehe ein fiktiver
disney galt er hat die auf drei
schneeflocken images geschrieben und
dass sie rausgehen soll also hat sie als
erwachsener mensch ich keine wahl da
muss ich natürlich raus gehen jetzt
versucht sie mit dem schneemann aus
flossen zu schreiben so nach dem motto
vielleicht dass er als mittelsmann
auftreten kann und die kontakte
herzustellen
das ist ein sehr guter gedanken das wird
bestimmt funktionieren sie ist ja
eigentlich jetzt am stärksten oder in
den wintermonaten november dezember
januar februar so das macht schon
irgendwie sinn macht sinn oder also oder
will er gerne von euch erzählen dass es
keinen sinn macht
will einer von euch mir erzählen dass es
keinen sinn macht im winter vor die tür
zu gehen nachts um einen disney
charaktere zu jagen ist einfach rum oder
war ja eigentlich nicht mehr da war
wieder so ein moment war so kurz für die
realisation reingekriegt hat so mag man
ab kurz so der verstand hat sich aus dem
mit dem hinteren gehirnbereich gemeldet
hat gesagt du rebecca was machen wir
hier eigentlich gerade hat es klaus
gedanken ich hab keine ahnung wo ich
suchen soll
keine ahnung ich habe jetzt einfach mal
hier ja auch das macht macht natürlich
sinn elsa hat er geschrieben
becker ich bin gab draußen also ich bin
irgendwo außerhalb des hauses irgendwo
auf dieser welt auf einer fläche von
keine ahnung 30 millionen
quadratkilometern und denkt sich so
perfekt dann gehe ich einfach mal vor
die tür weil ich ja schon finden
[Musik]
sind sie von spulen kurz geiler da zieht
sie mir gemacht irgendwie das abtritt
muster von von welchen stiefeln mit
absatz im turmzimmer diesmal vor 17
minuten vor sie aufgenommen hat kriegt
sie somit keine farbe so auf den boden
und sprüht sondern mit so einer
schablone so schuhabdrücke hin was
denken sich die passanten die der
vorbeilaufen
eindeutig schuhabdrücke von high heel
stiefel das liegt mir sehr
nach dem ersten zeichen von elser aus
glas sein kann sein das kann gut sein
wir sehen nämlich auch an der stelle das
da 6 oder sagen wir mal acht fußabdrücke
auf dem boden sind davor und danach
keine mehr macht aber das macht sinn
leute okay es macht sinn sie ist halt
kurz geflogen davor dann hat sie sich
entschieden
vielleicht laufe ich jetzt mal kurz acht
schritte und danach fliege ich wieder
alles klar ich jemanden suchen um 3 uhr
fallen wie solche helfen können bei
ihrer keine ahnung zauberkraft die außer
kontrolle geraten ist oder so ist wieso
sich noch die story so ausdenken muss
oder auch so ausdenkt ja warum es warum
suchen noch mal was ist normal dass der
sinn dahinter ganz davon abgesehen dass
bei jedem dieser videos überall steht
suche niemals gar keinen fall never ever
um drei uhr nachts person xy ist es
immer genau das was sie macht hier sind
schon wieder fußspuren sie gerade hier
das
ich weiß nicht ob die hiervon waren
etliche hoch lief es ist echt so geld
das muss man sich mal geben entweder
rebecca oder rebecca und irgend ein
freund von ihr gehen halt wirklich
nachts ich weiß nicht was ich glaube
nicht dass ich um drei uhr nachts zu
machen die werden es wahrscheinlich kann
um zehn uhr abends machen oder so weil
sie auch keinen bekommen so lange wach
zu bleiben
aber mitten in der nacht sind die in
irgend einer deutschen stadt und erst
sprüht einer mit kreide farbe den
schuhabdruck von einer disney princess
auf dem boden und der andere läuft dann
zehn minuten später der lang und also
ich hoffe jetzt bestimmt nicht diese
verraten straße sanken nur um ersatz zu
suchen nein also da bin ich raus das
macht sind das macht sinn finde ich gut
dass du da so konsequent geblieben bist
keine ahnung die ganze nacht über wach
bleiben und dann in der kälte draußen
der kamera in der hand langen zu laufen
und mit sich selbst zu reden weil man
eine disney prinzessin sucht das ist
okay ja das müssen wir darüber reden was
ja normal aber dann 30 meter eine straße
runter zu gehen
seid ihr wahnsinnig natürlich nicht
leute hört ihr das cover show
ich habe das video gerade gestoppt das
hat ihr wieder gestoppt aber woher kommt
die rückkehr ins haus ich habe keine
anderen tag auf dem die hohen kosten
seht ihr das ich glaube dass eine box
das komplett gefroren
ok alles klar also wir halten fest acer
acer hat den schneemann umgebracht weil
es wirklich nötig war becker also ich
hab nie draußen ganz durchgeschaut aber
ich glaube diese schneemann das
eigentlich ein cooler das ist nicht
eigentlich ein entspannter typ so die
man eigentlich mag warum musstest du
jetzt sterben lassen nochmals wir müssen
irgendwie diesen olaf hier raus bekommen
teilt ich kenne ich gar nicht anfassen
leute ok also auch soweit alles
weiterhin beim normalen unsere eine
unserer lieblings youtuber rennen ist
nicht nur nachts durch die nacht gerannt
mit einer kamera und hat mit sich selbst
geredet um eltern zu suchen nein sie hat
auch vorher eine eine kuscheltier figur
von olaf kurzerhand einfach mal
eingefrorene der gefriertruhe und dann
kurz vor dem videodreh da irgendwo
mitten in der nacht auf dem bürgersteig
platziert ich kann mir schwer vorstellen
dass sie an der hauptstraße ist und sich
da versteckt hat wenn dann eher im park
weil er hinten ist auch noch so einen
eingang
aber da gehe ich jetzt definitiv nicht
rein leute genau leute ja ganz wichtige
informationen für euch auch es ist
allgemein bekannt und hinreichend
erforscht in deutschland durch eine sehr
renommierte forscherin mit dem namen
professor dr
der punkt ging das disney charaktere
sich niemals an hauptstraßen aufhalten
ist sehr einfach zu laut wenn ihr im
disney charaktere treffen wollte zum 30
mai sollten niemals machen wissen wir ja
aber falls sie das vorhaben sollte dann
bitte nur im park suchen weil da sind
die das ich weiß nicht warum man oder
vier einfriert oder in ihm sind die
antworten das könnt ihr natürlich auch
sein also leute bei 50.000 daumen nach
oben schneidig olaf auf
[Musik]
sollte das war mein heutiger bericht
über geistes verwirrtheit und wahren
zustände in youtube deutschland die war
in der strauss kahn titel um ein
vorschlag ist video abchecken hier um
einen carbon ihren küsten macht's gut
und macht dieses experiment nicht mit
einem nachbarn